welcome to this video playing I keen on
and it's a new opponent let's see okay
oops let's play the main line for a
change I am a sick silence that's a good
line good alternative tonight bd7 let's
play by an idea in his blood
Championship match in 2012 against boris
gelfand so for now or not and then I
think he can take I think you start with
this but I'm not not totally positive
is he for move now I really forgot all
that that's it it's not very ambitious
maybe takes and Bishop e2 or so
what's there to think here doorbell it
probably doorbell mmm pizza delivery
things like that yeah we should be five
limbs completely completely wrong so I
have to basically take with the night
yeah it looks very decent very decent
for black this kind of situation yet
it's got a good good isolated queen
point position Wow
want to go to h6 en right that's that's
a weird plant never seen that one okay
so let's put this here right to prevent
anything coming to f5 hmm and also if
Roya is in opening up against the
strange piece down
jump don't really see anything right
there I don't agree don't see the point
of putting the night down on h6 it if it
was quite quite a serious thing let's
prepare you for me maybe I could have
played it immediately but ok so if
former Teague's night eggs I and it's it
to release this attention very early the
debt I don't like about it so maybe I
can play this this and then if I
efore is still the idea if it goes
Bishop before I also can go 92 something
like that Wow Bishop h3 it may be but ok
I'm going for now not hesitating here
anymore threatening me five or so and
takes
so h6 is under fire a h7s under fire and
he I have Bishop f4 which should at
least probably win win a pawn Knight g4
is also not bad but okay let's let's
play that move and ask questions later
threatening Bishop t6 at Bishop h7 now
and also taking on f5 so just just the
pawn right let's just take the pawn
check night g5 is this a good idea or
not one
probably just just dropping this bag is
good I'd like to have the Queen on the
Kings side as king as weekend no Queen
Queen D ugh sorry Queen B to D for H for
this kind of this kind of route would be
great
yeah it's a pretty good plane which he
prevented however for the night is
hanging on d6 Bishop Bishop a sixer
that's the ultimate computer move just
snatching pawns left and right now not
not don't want that what am I going to
do though it's probably good though it's
probably just good taking that pond but
don't don't really want that do I get
somewhere to h4 not really am ok let's
take it that's really greedy greedy
chess
and just a moment there Bishop d3 now
it's okay not blundering stuff Queen
Queen d3
check time warning I might go there yeah
that's yeah this is this is what happens
if your snitch too much material check
sometimes get yourself into trouble okay
this is equal vices equal material i
thought it was to another F F the H
point Wow I was totally shocked from
over there thinking it's equal material
okay it's two pawns after all check
check
yeah that looks okay now yeah Jack
straight down can go for the beep on
check check check check check smell it
quite a bit of mousse am checkmate okay
jam a little bit cheeky their second
second second yeah the second part I
don't know Bishop a6 was the kind of
greedy move that is say sometimes
punished wow wow we can take their I'm
don't believe it Wow yes Queen g-form I
could have taken them ah I was thinking
this but this is that this is the
problem for this and black wins Wow
yeah yeah so I have to do this yeah this
is good attacking here and then you form
and this is nice now amazing here
everything's back in order I I a g4 was
immediately winning now I didn't answer
that especially considering that Bishop
f4 so is good I mean it's locked I
wasn't pressed from this is the point
this pin now is really decisive right
okay it is nice yeah I'm winning this
Nyjah 5 is probably better here but ok
this is not bad and this is the comp
movie 3d computer I should have this was
wrong am should have taken here jack
it's a bit more precise than the rook on
d 2 and this is an easy technical task
ok this is a bit bit awkward f3 ok f3
just sending the light back yeah let's
check that wasn't very convincing but
the night and get down at the pond
should should be laughs even though i'm
not very active ok well thanks for
watching